A, C, E, D, B, K.
No, this isn't some random, out-of-order alphabet.
These are vitamins,...
...and just like letters build words,...
...they're the building blocks that keep the body running.
Vitamins are organic compounds we need to ingest in small amounts to keep functioning.
They're the body's builders, defenders and maintenance workers,...
...helping it to build muscle and bone, make use of nutrients,...
...capture and use energy and heal wounds.
If you need convincing about vitamin value,...
...just consider the plight of olden-day sailors,...
...who had no access to vitamin-rich fresh produce.
They got scurvy.
But vitamin C, abundant in fruits and vegetables,...
...was the simple antidote to this disease.
While bacteria, fungi and plants produce their own vitamins,...
...our bodies can't, so we have to get them from other sources.